when we went to Twitter headquarters the
day before the Takeover he was having
Andrew and um James as two young cousins
and other people from the autopilot team
going over lines of code and musk
himself sat there with a laptop on the
second floor of the building looking at
the lines of code that had been written
by Twitter engineers and they decided
they were going to fire 85 percent of
them because they had to be all in and
this notion of psychological safety and
mental days off and
working remotely he said either and then
it came up uh actually one of his um
I think it was one of the cousins or
maybe Ross Nordin came up with the idea
of let's not be so rough and just fire
all these people let's ask them do you
really want to be all in because this is
going to be hardcore it's going to be
intense you get to choose but by
midnight tonight we want you to check
the box I'm hardcore all in I'll be
there in person I'll work you know as
much or that's not for me I've got a
family I got work balance
and you got different type of people
that way and different stages of their
life I was a little bit more hardcore
and all in when I was in my 20s than
when I was you know in my 50s and you
write about this it's a really nice idea
actually that there's two camps and you
find out I don't I wonder how true this
is it it rings true you can just ask
people which Camp are you in are you the
kind of person that Prides themselves
and enjoy staying up to 2 A.M
programming or whatever or do you see
the value of quote-unquote you know
about life work life balance all this
kind of stuff and it's interesting I
mean you like you you could people
probably divide themselves in different
stages in life and you can just ask them
and it makes sense for certain companies
in certain stages of their development
to be like uh we always have teams it
doesn't even have to be a whole company
and you're right it goes back to what I
was saying about rule the first secret
is sort of know thyself obviously comes
from Plato and uh everything comes from
played on Socrates but
um
and decide on this stage of my life am I
do I want to be a hackathon all in all
night and change the world or do I want
to bring wisdom and stability but also
have balance I think it's good to have
different companies with different
styles the problem was Twitter was at
almost one extreme with yoga studios and
mental health days off and uh enshrining
psychological safety as one of the
mantras that people should never feel
psychologically threatened and he a
member of the bitter laugh he Unleashed
when he kept hearing that word he said
no I like the words hardcore I like
intensity I like a intense sense of
urgency as our operating principle well
yeah they're people that way as well and
so know who you are and know what type
of Team you want to build versus
psychological safety and too many birds
everywhere oh yeah a lot of times musk
did things I go what the hell yeah the
Magnum was changing the name Twitter and
getting rid of the birds hey man there's
a lot invested in that brand
but when I watched him he thought okay
these sweet little chirpy birds tweeting
away in the name Twitter it's
not hardcore it's not intense and so for
better and for worse I think he's taking
Acts
into the hardcore realm with people who
post hardcore things with people with
hardcore views
it's not
a
polite playpen
for
the blue checked
anointed Elite
and I thought okay this is going to be
bad the whole thing's gonna fall apart
well it has had problems but the
hardcore intensity of it has also meant
that there's new things happening there
so it's very Elon Musk
to not like this sweetness of birds
chirping and tweeting and saying I want
something more hardcore